russia's president vladimir putin is on
a rare trip outside of russia since the
invasion of ukraine he will hold talks
with turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan and iranian president ibrahim
raisi
syria is on the official agenda but
putin and erdogan are also expected to
discuss a u.n backed proposal to resume
exports of ukrainian grain
millions of tons of grain are stuck in
ukrainian ports threatening a global
food crisis
let's get the perspective from turkey
and bring in our correspondent yulia han
who is following all of this from
istanbul for us why are today's talks so
important julia
well the actual summit later today
officially focuses on syria as you
mentioned russia iran and turkey support
opposing sides in this war but despite
their troubled relations they have met
many times in recent years in this exact
format but now that ukraine also
features on the agenda this is an
opportunity for the turkish president to
project influence and power regionally
and internationally he will get the
chance to hold his first meeting with
vladimir putin since russia invaded
ukraine
in february and that is very significant
because turkey is a nato member but we
also know that president erdogan has
performed a delicate balancing act
between russia and ukraine russia and
the west he tried to emerge as the key
mediator in this war and that is
something that's been viewed i believe
with both hope and skepticism in western
capitals uh erdogan has offered for
months to meet with vladimir putin now
that is going to happen today he will be
the first nato leader to sit down face
to face face with putin since late
february
and turkey has also been trying to
negotiate an end to russia's blockade of
millions of tons of ukrainian grain
exports erdogan and putin expected to
discuss that
tell us a little bit more
well exactly this is what edwin and
putin are expected to talk about today a
possible deal for a grain corridor that
would allow ukraine to export some 20
million tonnes of grain wire the black
sea to world markets a grain that has
been trapped inside silos since russia
invaded the country and that is urgently
needed as the world faces shortages and
higher food prices in fact official
talks on this matter are expected to
continue here in istanbul this week with
delegations from russia ukraine turkey
and the united nations and turkish
negotiators have been hopeful that a
deal could be signed this week so i'm
assuming um mr erdogan will try to
convince putin not to throw a spanner
into the works
the meeting in tehran will also include
talks on syria what does erdogan hope to
achieve there
well the situation in syria as you know
has always been very complicated iran
and russia support assad regime forces
while turkey has been supporting
opposition rebels but analysts say
erdogan went to tehran with a particular
request to get a green light from his
iranian and russian counterparts for
another turkish military offensive in
syria against kurdish fighters ankara
considers terrorists but both iran and
russia have voiced opposition to these
plans moreover russia controls the
airspace over syria so it would be very
risky for erdogan to push ahead with
this without an okay from raisi and
putin yulia han thank you very much
and turkish president rechab tayyip
erdogan has again threatened to block
sweden and finland's bid to join nato
meantime
he wants to make sure that they stick to
the assurances that they gave last month
that they would clamp down on kurdish
groups turkey views as terrorists for
some kurds living in sweden the future
now seems uncertain
kurds in stockholm are protesting
demands from turkish president recep
tayyip erdogan for the swedish
government to crack down on their
presence
[Applause]
especially demonstrations like this one
with a prominent showing by the pkk a
kurdish militant group officially
designated as a terrorist organization
by the swedish government for its armed
attacks against turkey
erdogan is threatening to block sweden's
pending membership in nato if it doesn't
take action he additionally claims a
deal made with sweden and finland to
step up counter-terrorism cooperation
and exchange intelligence means the
swedish government has agreed to
extradite dozens of people erdogan
accuses of terrorism the trilateral memo
which is public contains no such pledge
but that's not enough to reassure bulent
kenish a turkish newspaper editor
sentenced to life in prison in ankara
for criticizing the erdogan regime
kenish thought he was safe after
escaping to sweden in 2016. it is a new
life for me
i took a big
breath and said that okay
now
the danger
remain behind but the danger didn't
remain behind in february swedish
authorities informed kenish turkey was
demanding his extradition he had to
testify and says his case is currently
in the supreme court i am a just
journalist and academic
i just criticized erdogan regime ankara
accuses him of many crimes including of
being a gulenist a follower of an exiled
religious leader residing in the u.s
whom erdogan has labeled a terrorist
kennish has found his name on lists of
people erdogan says must be handed over
before he'll approve swedish membership
in nato
could you ever have imagined that you
would be in this situation where you
feel like your life is a bargaining chip
under normal conditions i am sure that
the swedish system continued to protect
me i am not 100 sure right now he's not
alone since erdogan leveled his demands
against sweden kurds who support groups
considered illegal in turkey are nervous
even though the swedish government
rejects suggestions it's made any deals
on extraditions with ankara amina
kakabava is a swedish parliamentarian
with iranian kurdish roots the turkish
government has also called her a
terrorist and demanded she be sent to
turkey even though she says she doesn't
support the pkk and she's not turkish
people are also very worried about my
security and their own security of
course
even in abroad you know
if you have your name in some list
abroad
they can help the turkish government you
know that is very dangerous nato hopes
swedish membership gets quick approval
from allies parliaments but analyst aris
lin says he suspects erdogan may well
drag this dispute out as he runs for
re-election next june
this plays very well into the turkish
narrative
i mean uh
i think it's an attempt to shift focus
from the very high inflation that uh
makes it very hard for people to to
um
for their everyday life and also for for
the upcoming presidential and
parliamentary election
kennish hopes he won't have to wait that
long to know his own fate dignified life
comes to end for me
if i
deported
he's hoping to learn by september that
he can stay in sweden